now a very warm welcome
everyone i welcome you all to the first
session of
machine learning for biomedical drug
discovery program
it's an online program which is
co-hosted by pine biotech
faba academy pharma toppers and pro
biotechnica
so let me start with the introduction
about us we are a us-based
bioinformatics company who is
working with multiple academic and
commercial collaborators to develop easy
to use analytical tools
and our mission is to make
bioinformatics more accessible
we are doing this by providing training
and tools that help students and
researchers make discovery
using next generation sequencing data
science and other bioinformatics
technologies and
tools our mixed logic research-based
training programs are a result of close
collaboration between buying biotech and
numerous academic institutions
that have participated in content
evaluation
curriculum review and project design and
as
a result the omex logic programs have
been thoroughly tested around the world
and are known to lead to excellent
outcomes for students with minimal
bioinformatics background
including biology and biomedical study
majors as well as faculty interested in
bioinformatics data science and
biomedical research
and my name is analika ray and i am the
omixlogic community manager responsible
for daily interaction with thousands of
users
that are a part of a bioinformatics
community which is managed by pine
biotech
i am honored to have been working with a
company that collectively has
amazing experience in this area
including the other co-founders of the
company
dr alfred tauber who comes from a
medical background with
with an expertise in oncology immunology
and biochemistry of inflammation
and one of his major projects is the
establishment of the trouble
bioinformatics research center
which has been at the core of what we do
dr leonard brosky is the director of
toba bioinformatics research center
and is an expert in bioinformatics and
biostatistics
he has numerous publications and
bioinformatics and over the course of
his career he has developed multiple
novel algorithmic approaches to
biomedical data analysis
and these have been widely used in basic
and translational research
in biotechnology pharmaceutical r d
agriculture
and basic research so our platform is a
result of hard work by
some of the people who are mentioned
here on the right julia panna who was an
expert by informatician
and has helped prepare many of the
materials that we would be using
avi detox key who is a computer
scientist and leads the development of g
by info platform that we would use
dr harpreet she has an expertise in the
applications of statistical machine
learning techniques
on biomedical data and the development
of prediction tools and databases
and she looks after the curriculum
development by informatics
and data science course development for
the company
and then we have dr mohit mazum
dharvadas who is an expert
who is experienced by implementation
with multiple publications
in peer-reviewed journals and
collaborations in
industry and academia and over the past
several years he has been developing
collaborations with universities
as a mentor and project lead for
omixlogic training and research
fellowship
now coming back to the program this
program is designed to address the
challenges associated
with rapid growth of high throughput
data including omix technologies which
gave rise to data driven discovery in
life sciences
as a result there is a significant
demand for data science skills and
experience with bioinformatics methods
of analysis
once a peripheral discipline you could
easily
outsource bioinformatics it as it is
quickly becoming the mainstream
in life science research many high
impact journals will only publish if a
rigorous bioinformatics analysis is
included in the results
and methods portions of the publication
and in this course we would explain the
logic of bioinformatic analysis
and allow for user friendly applications
of biostatistical and machine learning
techniques to a variety of biomedical
challenges
now i would like to pass it on to the
prime biotic
ceo ilia brodsky to take this session
ahead over to you india thank you so
much
and uh great to see all of you here
today
um so uh first of all welcome
to the program and uh i want to kind of
briefly
outline how this program is going to be
structured so that you're all
aware of the topics that will be covered
and also of how to make the most of your
time
in this program so let me share my
screen
so this program on data science is going
to be a little bit different from the
previous data science
programs that we have done so we have
partnered with
some additional partners like faba which
is
an association of biotechnology
companies in asia and also
pharma-toppers
that bring together experts from the
pharmaceutical industry to give you
an overview of how data science can be
used not only
in the domain of biomedical data
analysis but also in other domains which
we will hear about
in just a few minutes but let me start
off
for those of you that are new to data
science and how does data science relate
to bioinformatics itself so as you know
data science is the applications
of information technologies which are
data storage
organization retrieval different data
formats and manipulation of data or data
wrangling
the application of tools from
statistical analysis analysis
and design of different types of tests
to hypothesis testing
and then the specialization domain what
does it apply to
because data science is such a broad
topic
and could be applied to literally any
kind of data
so the interesting thing is that if you
think about bioinformatics it actually
has
all of the same components except for in
the application
domain it is specific to biological data
and so that's what makes data science in
application to biomedical challenges
so exciting especially when you consider
the amount
of data and the different types of data
that are being generated
in a variety of biomedical research
studies and translational research
so before we go on i want everybody to
take a pause from this presentation we
would love to get to know you but also
before we even get into the topics of
the program
we want to share with you some free
resources as we are getting started
so let's go on to our portal called
learn omixlogic.com
and i want to make sure that all of you
here today are familiar with some of the
free resources that you can get started
with today
so this is the link
on this link you will find a number of
relevant resources so you can
log in first please let me know once
you're here
essentially to log in you go to the
login
tab and you will see here that you can
create an account with your email and
password
or with one of the social media networks
if you have a profile there
so please let me know how many of you
have already created an account
you can put number one in the chat box
if you have already created an account
all right thank you emmanuel okay
great thank you everyone
okay if you have already created an
account
you should be able to go to your profile
so on this profile there are several
important things to remember
on this profile you will see your
picture
obviously we want to have a name and a
face so that we can
connect with you there are some social
media
accounts that you can connect to your
profile so we would love to stay in
touch on
linkedin on facebook on instagram
know about your research work and
twitter
so please update some of this
information that you're comfortable
sharing
you can also put a short
blurb about yourself so give us a sense
of who you are are you a student are you
a faculty member
maybe you're already a trainer and an
expert so we would love to get to know
you
and then what you will start seeing is
as we go through the course work
in this program you will get points
these points are grouped by achievements
and those achievements include
completing a lesson completing a course
running a pipeline
running a specific code block maybe
completing a session
and things like that
and then you will see your uh
program if you already registered for
the program
appear right here so you will be able to
see the programs that you're a part of
by going to this tab
and you can see here i have a list of
them so let's take a look at how does
this actually work
so if we go to the main site you can go
to programs
and this is the program that we are
discussing today machine learning for
biomedical drug discovery
and here you have the information about
the program itself with a little
overview of the program
all of the sessions
and then you will also see some of the
elements of the program
how they will fit together is the
subject of today's session so
we will provide you with training which
is a combination of online sessions
self-study guides that you will find on
this portal
including some practical exercises that
you'll be able to do
as you go through to build up your
technical skills
after you complete the coursework you
will get certificates
so all of our coursework is certified
and reviewed by multiple institutions
and partners
and so you will get a certificate that
you can share
you will have access to mentorship so
the people that you see
today in this program are some of the
mentors that will be available during
the program
depending on the level of your access
that you've purchased with the access to
the license
you will have an option to schedule a
meeting with
a mentor we'll also go over some of the
cloud tools today
so we'll show you how to utilize our big
data analysis platform
and we'll also show you how to utilize
some of the coursework
that includes practical skills that you
can develop right
in the browser importantly this is
more than just a training program
essentially we view it as a first step
to collaborate so those of you that are
joining today
and starting with the program that's why
we want you to complete your profile
your profile is going to be an important
place where others can learn about you
and connect with you
and hopefully you leave this program not
just
knowing how to do several things but
also getting connected
with people that you can form
long-term collaborations with so the
best way to do that
is actually to join our linkedin group
or a group on social media like facebook
how many of you are on linkedin i'm on
linkedin too much
but those of you that are on linkedin
like myself
you will be able to connect with me
obviously but also with all of us here
and the way to do that is to join our
omics logic
group so i'll paste the link right here
okay why is it important to join a
media social media group of people that
are associated with logic the reason
is um because first of all
you will find that there are over two or
sorry 1 000 members here that are
experts
in a variety of different domains
including people that work for
biotechnology companies pharmaceutical
companies
faculty at different universities around
the world
including the us europe india
and other places you will find here
people that have completed
our training in the past and you've see
you will see
how they develop over time uh we have
our research fellows that
post here their research project so
you'll be able to see
what they have been able to do and
achieve and obviously all of us are here
as well
so if you hated the program you can tag
us if you love the program you can tag
us as well
so that's something that we encourage
all of you to do
in this program as well
okay so as i mentioned uh all of the
coursework
come with a certificate of completion so
let me briefly describe
what the certificate of completion is
and how to achieve that stage
so a program consists of several
different elements
these are going to be online sessions
that we will review in just a few
minutes
it includes some coursework that you
have to complete and it is certified as
well
and it also includes some of the
point-based system that we have
on our portal so the point-based system
allows us
and you to track your progress as you go
through the different stages and
assignments that are presented to you in
this program
so we expect everyone to get to a
minimum
of 10 000 points and that gets you to a
level of expertise
that know that we all know that you have
completed some of the basic
training on the portal once you reach a
level of 10
000 points you are also eligible to work
on an independent project so all of you
hopefully will get to that point
and if you're interested in developing a
showcase
for what you have learned and maybe
how that aligns with your research
interests you are welcome to submit
a research project proposal to submit a
research project proposal you will
get a form a personal invitation to
submit a project proposal
and once you submit it we will try to
assist you as much as possible
in completing that research project in
the duration of this program
if you want to continue and work on that
research proposal
even after the program is over you're
welcome to do that
you have an option to join our research
fellowship program
importantly that research fellowship
over the summer
will come with a research symposium in
august
where you will have access to experts
and judges from
top universities in the us that will be
able to comment
on your project presentation and so if
you're interested in that
please do reach out to our team sonalika
here
dr mohit mazumdar myself you can reach
us out by
email uh so narika if you could please
list out the emails here so
everyone would be able to join
okay so before i go on are there any
questions about this
how many of you have already joined the
linkedin group
all right perfect thank you priya has
anyone else joined the
all right great thank you nish
all right i see a few of you could i
repeat the
part about points yes so again the
portal is free
anyone can join the portal and you have
access to some
free courses that you can go through and
kind of understand how they're
structured
for those of you that are part of the
program we will track your points
every time you complete an achievement
let me briefly show how
that works
okay so here you can go to this link
just type in achievements
you will see everybody and their
activity
on the portal
okay you can see that every time
somebody
completes some step like a lesson or a
course
you will get some points sometimes it's
50
sometimes it's one sometimes it's 500
100 etc
and that's how you get to the 10 000
point mark
what are the courses that you consider
most important to complete
okay so this program is about
data science so what i would recommend
is go to this tab
courses and start looking for
introduction you will see here the
following
courses introduction to bioinformatics
introduction to data science and python
an introduction
to data science and r if you're just
getting started
you can start with getting started with
bioinformatics in python and getting
started with bioinformatics in r
so these are some of the courses that i
recommend there's also a course for
those of you that
need to refresh your molecular biology
terminology
and kind of how does this all fit in i
recommend going through our course
called bites and molecules
is it possible to take up the fellowship
program after gaining 10 000 points
yes you can join the research fellowship
is a program that you can learn about
right here go to research
and that program is designed
specifically for those of you that would
like to spend the next
three to six months working on
independent research projects
but those are um again not relevant to
this program today so
let's go back to the program at hand
which is called
omics logic data science okay and i will
pass this on
very soon to my collaborator
dr sujeet who will speak about data
science
but i first want to make sure that we go
through this introduction
so our typical program on data science
includes
the understanding of the various omics
data types formats and associated
challenges
exploratory data analysis and processing
that data to prepare it for analysis
application of supervised and
unsupervised machine
learning methods to exploration of
biomedical data
in this particular program we're going
to expand
the number of topics and we're going to
also talk about
things like deep learning neural
networks
we're going to talk about natural
language processing
and some other important tools that are
relevant to biomedical research but also
relevant to some of the
other data types however
what we will try to do is give you a
complete road map for data science so
this is a month-long program
in this program you will find data sets
we will share with you some curated data
sets that you can practice with
you can explore and visualize making
sure that your visualization is
impactful and accurate you will
understand
research methods as you read through
publications and you come across
different figures you'll understand what
they represent and hopefully
that will give you insight and
understanding
of how to apply data science skills and
methods
to a variety of biomedical research
topics so that's why we call this avex
ovixlogic so omixlogic the purpose of
this program is really to connect the
dots
and provide you with a variety of
different access points
so that you can continue and learn all
of these
important topics now briefly speaking
about
the sessions that are coming up today
we're talking about introduction to data
science
we will then talk about machine learning
algorithms
the application of data science to a
variety of domains including biomedical
research
on june 18th introduction to machine
learning
for next generation sequencing data
including transcriptomics genomics and
meta genomics
then we'll talk about unsupervised
machine learning clustering and data
mining
supervised machine learning
classification and finding different
signatures and big data and then we will
transition to a second part of the
program
which will be focused on an independent
project
so that is to develop a proposal
on how you could apply machine learning
tools to
a variety of important topics in
biomedicine
or associated topics
we'll then do some practical hands-on
sessions which will include
dimensionality reduction in r and python
clustering in r in python classification
or in python
evaluating your model accuracy and how
to then
take your model to production and then
how to work
on an independent research project
okay so this is today's session so we
have
started today's session but we will
transition into the topic the
introduction to data science
in just a few more minutes and before we
get started i wanted to
give you an overview of how this will
work
okay so the important separation here is
that we have two separate parts
and so in the beginning we will kind of
get oriented and introduced to the
important topics and then we will go
into
machine learning and ai and some
practical hands-on tools
and i want to briefly tell you about how
different types of machine
learning have been playing a big
impact on biomedical discovery
as you know the omics data types
continuously expand and evolve and so
it's important that
in many of these types of data there's
many many
thousands of features and because of
that it is complicated to apply
traditional statistical methods to get
accurate signal from this highly
variable
and heterogeneous data and so machine
learning
is very well applied to the challenges
associated to big omics data and that's
why
you can see in literature and in a
variety of different
outlets how machine learning has been
taking over
this area of biomedical discovery drug
discovery
and the application of to research to
basic research challenges
and especially this can be seen just by
looking at the
pace of data coming out from different
biomedical projects
so this comes as a challenge but also
as an opportunity so on one hand the
challenge
is that the data is growing in
complexity
and growing in velocity growing in
volume
on the other hand it's an opportunity
because many of these data sets
are generated by extremely qualified
and skilled technicians laboratory
technicians as well as biologists that
ask the right
questions and can generate very accurate
data about
very specific types of phenomena so when
we think about it
it's an opportunity if we just have the
tools to be able to work with this kind
of data
especially this can be seen with this
new pandemic
so as opposed to previous pandemics and
previous
chronic diseases or even some important
developments
around the world epidemics that have
sprung out in different places
this pandemic has been characterized one
by huge volumes of data that have been
produced
number two real time sharing of such
data so it's not like the pandemic is
over and we're just getting access to
the data
every single day there have been
thousands of new
data points deposited in public
repositories that
anyone can access and number three this
data has been
increa increasingly diverse that
includes
genomic data about the viruses
themselves
population health data about who and how
people
get gets infected and how do they get
sick
including transcriptomic data about the
response
to the different types of infections
including many other different types of
data
and so now that we have this almost
real-time access to such biomedical
data the question is what can we
actually do with this data
and how can we utilize this data to gain
insights into what's going on
and to understand how we can gain
insights into this we need to understand
what are some of these technologies that
are generating
omics data to describe and characterize
the molecular uh drivers of these
diseases
and this includes many different types
of omics data including
phenomics genomics epigenomics
transcriptomics metagenomics and many
others
now what's unique about this kind of
data is that this data has to be
processed
so this data has to be prepared
before it could be analyzed and that
includes specific
processing steps that are related to the
way that this data is generated and so
what we'll do
in this program is also introduce you to
some of the tools
that you need to have to be able to
construct
logical workflows from raw data
to structure data and as a result as you
learn about the logic behind some of
these pipelines you'll be able to
prepare the data for analysis and
make sure that it answers the specific
question that you have in mind
about this type of data now ultimately
the challenge is not just processing and
preparing the data for analysis but it's
in the integration of
multiple different data types that are
describing the same problem and that
includes ability to perform statistical
analysis
data mining structural analysis single
cell deconvolution
map these complex relationships and
ultimately
extract some meaningful insights so in
this program
we'll talk about all parts of this
process from
how the data was prepared to generate
the data set that we're looking at
to then data processing or how to clean
and organize the data and prepare it for
analysis
then we'll talk about exploratory data
analysis how we can
visualize and mine data for patterns to
eliminate
noise and focus on the signal and then
how to structure your analysis with
a specific strategy to understand
how different statistical models or
different types of methods and
algorithms
apply to a particular problem and then
how we can
get some meaningful insights or
inference what can we extract
from this type of analysis that is
relevant to the problem at hand
so there's many different types of
unstructured data
but the important part is that there's
much more unstructured data
than structured data and the problem
with unstructured data is that you can't
really
analyze it and so many data scientists
unfortunately are excited about how we
can apply different
latest techniques and models to train on
this data
but if you don't have access to
structured data essentially that's
impossible so we will spend some
considerable time
talking about structuring data when you
structure data
data could be organized into many
different objects and so we will also
review
how different data objects and different
types of structures
could be useful for a variety of
information
points that are in our input data and so
we'll talk about
vectors data frames matrices arrays
and others we'll talk about data
normalization
and exploration to understand what are
some of the prominent features of the
data
and how we can transform it into the
data types and data structures
that are most useful for different types
of analysis
and we will talk about some statistical
properties of data
that allow us to think about experiment
design
finally we will focus on some
biologically meaningful data analysis
and exploration so that we can
understand the different types of
visualization techniques and what they
mean
and go on to data mining and
classification and that includes
different types of classification
techniques and different types of
data mining approaches that again are
best used in a variety of scenarios that
we will describe
using project examples
now many of you are probably coming to
this program
already knowing some coding and knowing
how to
organize your infrastructure on your own
computer but some of you
might not be and so what we wanted to do
is to make sure that this program
is accessible to those that have a
coding background
and those that do not so if you don't
have any coding background
that's absolutely okay we will go
through all of the basics how is code
organized and then you will have an
ability to practice some of these things
right in your browser before you take it
out of the browser and onto your
computer so
how many of you already have rstudio
installed on your computer
okay priya marcelina okay
great excellent how many of you have
python
installed on your computer
okay great so what are some of your
what are some of your um favorite
uh environments where you uh use
python so somebody mentioned pycharm
anyone else collab
okay jupiter jupiter google co-lab
vs code all right excellent
visual studio code bs code yep all right
excellent so
those of you that is there anyone here
that
does not have rstudio installed yet
okay so for those of you that do not
have
let me show you uh for those of you that
do not have
our studio or python installed
you can go to introduction to
uh for example here you have here
directions on how to do it
rstudio and in the one on python you
have instructions on how to get started
with python
so what's important is that you need to
install several things on your computer
you need to get to know the environment
and you need to understand the logic
behind different packages
and different ways of running your code
so this is an important way to get
started for those of you that have
already gotten that experience already
you can go on into the more advanced
topics there as well
okay so we talked about coding
all right now the sessions that we will
have
like today's session are going to be
interactive sessions
that are going to be supplemented by
some of these online materials so it's
important to come to the session
when you are ready and so when you're
ready
you probably have to complete some
course or some lesson or some practical
assignment
and then that is the way that you can
leverage these
interactive sessions in the best way
possible so the interactive sessions are
to review
they are to ask questions they are to
get help to get you unstuck
but to be a full part of the program you
have to be an
active participant so for those of you
that have already joined the program
we have a slack channel that you will
get invited to
after you complete your registration and
so
how many of you have already joined the
slack channel
for this data science program
right great all right so some of you
have if you have not
but you have already joined the program
then you need to
ask us you need to reach out to somalika
marketing at pine bio
she's our community manager and she will
help you get
set up so that you can ask questions you
can post your progress
or you can address any specific
challenges that you see
maybe something wasn't covered and
things like that now all of the sessions
are going to be recorded
so after the session is recorded it's
uploaded to
our youtube channel and you will get a
recording right there
on the program page as well as on the
slack channel
all right so we already signed up let me
briefly
show you our big data analysis platform
so that all of you are also signed up
there
go with me to server.tbio.info
and let me know if you are there you can
use
the exact same login and password that
you got
when you registered for the program
okay so anyone in fact that has
registered
on the learn portal will have an account
for those of you that are not from are
not a part of the program yet you can
still do a demo so let me briefly
demonstrate
what this platform does
okay please let me know once you're on
this link maybe put something in the
chat so i know you're
all there thank you
all right anyone else i'll give it a
couple more minutes priya
thank you
all right so once you are logged in
and i can see that i'm logged in just by
hovering over this profile
icon let's go and we'll try
two things so as you can see this
platform is organized into the following
sections this is
for big data processing and here you
have some
things that you can try without any
coding so i will show you two things
the first one is an example of a
processing pipeline
so i'll go into this demo there's no
need to upload anything but it helps you
understand the logic behind the analysis
so you can see here the different steps
you can then perform
pre-processing or cleaning up the raw
data
and filtering it for all kinds of
technical variation
then we perform mapping and so you learn
about the reeds and the exons and how
they are spliced together to form
transcripts then you can find
how the transcripts are added on into
the annotation file or the gtf
file and then finally finally how do we
quantify
the abundance of gene expression so one
of the data types we will deal with
is gene expression and that is
transcriptomic data
so here you will find some of the
outputs that you will need
to work with transcriptomic data from a
curated project that you can learn about
on our portal okay so this was example
number one
example number two once you have that
data already
you can perform what's called principal
component
analysis and inside of this pipeline
you will also get code for
r studio so if you want to modify the
code
and you want to run it on your computer
you can do it from right here so again
this platform combines big data
processing
directly from ncbi or from your own
computer
with downstream analysis techniques many
of them
are implemented in r and you will be
able to download the r script from right
here
okay so any other questions before we
move on
okay if there are no other questions i
want to introduce our speaker for today
dr
sujeet uh he is the founder of
pharma-toppers and the co-founder of
octam
pvt ltd he has a phd in chemo
informatics and drug design
as well as a.i in drug discovery
durba we will address all the other
questions at the end of the session so
please hold on to your questions
and sujit i will pass it on to you
thank you ilya
i welcome again all of you guys
and good morning good afternoon good
evening wherever you are part of the
globe so
let me share my screen
so could you please confirm if my screen
is visible
yes sir it's visible thank you
so guys uh as a part of entire one month
program
this is a introduction to data science
how we can use it for a life science
in this program i would be talking more
on a data science perspective
and that something about some
mathematical part of a data science and
machine learning
what exactly is happening but definitely
i'll correlate most of the terminologies
most of the things to the life science
or
pharma pharma data
so uh considering that we have uh
participants from various background
maybe from life science maybe from
genomics maybe
maybe from parma and maybe from a
computer science
so guys have you ever wondered how
amazon ebay suggests
items for you to buy you used to get
some notifications right
have you do you know gmail filters your
email
before it comes to you as a spammer or
not not
non-spam categories hope you
you might be knowing many of time you
might have seen that okay my my email
has gone
uh my email has gone into spam folder
maybe
google can tag that particular email as
a spam
if you are watching netflix if you are a
regular customer of netflix
so do you know netflix predicts how uh
what are the shows you like
i mean let's see if you are watching any
video or any movie in a netflix
and netflix also gives some suggestion
based on your based on your activity
previous activity
into the platform but do you know all
these things are actually a part of ai
or actually part of
machine learning deep learning or
broadly we can say your data science
so apart from this uh these examples are
actually considered to a very general
public to just getting into
this particular program uh but if i have
to specifically talk about
life science or uh pharmacy graduate
or any uh any other bioinformatics
graduate
so guys if you have no we can predict
the toxicity of a drug molecule using
data science
using machine learning using deep
learning uh
if you are a life science graduate you
know you can draw a molecular structure
in a various molecule editor tools
once you draw a structure you can save
the structure into a image
a 2d image of the molecule in a png
format
also along with the image you can
predict the toxicity of a molecule there
has been several paper
people have published about how we can
predict the toxicity of molecule just
from an
image so this is all of this is because
of the computer vision technology which
is also a part of data science
so guys you can do many things using
data science or using machine learning
deep learning uh
if you have heard about there are
several other companies out there in the
market like benevolent ai
extension and several other startup
company now they are
becoming a giant pharma companies they
have already
partnered with several companies like
astrazeneca pfizer
very big companies know what is etc
and as you know the entire drug
discovery process
it actually takes around 15 to 20 years
and around
4 billion dollars of cost to to to have
entire drug discovery process but the
act the entire discovery process has
been reduced down to
only one year just because of the ai
just because of the
ai in drug discovery so if you are a
life science graduate if so if you are a
farmer
pharma graduate if you are a phd or if
you are a research
researcher we would request all of you
to
apply data science machine learning or
artificial intelligence technologies in
your day-to-day
research activities or it is a highly
recommended
course for each each one of you
so how you can define a data science or
a data scientist you know
the one who knows data science the one
who works in the field of data science
is actually called as a data scientist
in a in an industry so at the bottom if
you can see a person who is better at
statistics
than any software engineer and better at
software engineering than any
statistician
is actually called as a data scientist
and you could have heard about data
jobs data scientist jobs are the most
loved jobs and
you could find many vacancies out there
in the market for a data science
and in this course we have another
course starting from tomorrow where in
vr
we are giving practical sessions on a
chemo informatics and a drug discovery
if you could join both
of this course you will have complete
idea
understanding of how we can apply data
science in
our machine learning or deep learning in
in your drug discovery process or in
your biological or chemical data
so moving forward data science is a
practice of mining
large data set of raw data both
structured and unstructured
so here structured you can say a label
data a label data you can say
that let's say you if you have a
particular sentence let's say for a
particular molecule you know that is
that benzene kind of structure is
actually a benzene molecule and
let's say a particular molecule is
actually a paracetamol molecule
if you know any data point which belongs
to any particular tax
that is called a structure data but
let's say you have a bunch of
molecules but you don't know uh the name
of those molecules or you if you don't
know smiles of those molecules you just
have those images of this molecule
then actually that is called as a
unstructured data
so data science is a practice of mining
large data to identify patterns and
extract actionable insights from them
so uh actually this is an
interdisciplinary field
it includes statistics if you are
to be called as a data scientist you
need to have you need to know some of
the statistics
you should have some understanding of a
computer science you should have some
predictive analytics capability
you should know machine learning deep
learning a little bit of machine
learning deep learning computer vision
or natural language processing and you
should
you should be capable enough to find out
some of the inferences
from your data and uh
existence of this data science
technologies like machine learning and
data saving data data thirsty algorithms
like deep learning came just because of
the big data
so if you could see if you are a human
being you are actually
generating a data and then with a data
scientist he actually does some
analysis of the data and then data
scientists give inference or a
prediction of
prediction based on that data by
applying some uh algorithms techniques
so uh let us talk about data and their
languages
what actually important for uh data
science as a data scientist
why we are learning data science it's
just because why this
why this particular field came into
existence why this machine learning deep
learning everyone is using this
algorithm
just because data is growing
exponentially and yes for machine
learning deep learning or any other data
science algorithm
the data is actually a fuel for those
algorithm and you know
data is not only fuel for the algorithm
but yes also for the entire world
so the inter and as you might be knowing
internet
users are generating more than 2.
billions per
bytes of a data every day so
about 90 percent of this huge amount of
data gets generated
in the most recent two years according
to the sources like ibm and
netflix so and you can even in the
coming days coming
coming years you could see even more
number of
zetabyte of data could may generate in
every hour or
every day so uh being a data scientist
what exactly
you should know what are those libraries
i would more focus on a python but yes
being a data side
scientist if you know r you can work you
can
you can use many of those algorithms and
you can do lots of data analysis process
using r uh i am a i'm a python expert i
i like python because you could find
more of a libraries
related to data science in a python
python uh framework
so uh me out of the several
data science libraries pandas is the
number one library which is actually
most important data scientists should
learn about
numpy scipy numpy is for the
mathematical calculations
scipy is also for some calculations
scrappy if you want to
scrap some data matplotlib if you want
to plot some
plot some data statistics analysis if
you want to do
you can use sebum as well cyclic line
contains several machine learning
algorithms wherein you just have to call
the package and you can
you can you go good to go to develop
your own model
and again psychic image tensorflow and
librosa can be used also
for can be these are the very useful
packages for any
data scientist beginner or expertise
so uh okay as we are talking about data
science so let me directly
jump into data science life cycle what
exactly the steps involve
being a part of data science day-to-day
activities data scientist day-to-day
activities
so and then after this data science life
cycle we will look it into
all other machine learning deep learning
uh all other algorithms and there
and there's some some mathematics behind
those algorithm as well
along with some life science specific to
life science problems or
specific tools as a life science example
so what could be the first step being a
data scientist uh
what you would do very as a first step
or
how data science workflow works on so
define defining a problem statement
to work with any data science problem or
any any
uh any uh to to so to to bring data
science approach to any of the problem
you should have a
perfect well defined problem statement
if you don't have you
can work on to define perfect problem
statement
then the way the biggest the most
important step is data collection
having a very good amount of data and
having a good quality of data
is actually a very strong
strong base for any any data modeling
process or
data science life cycle you need to
collect good
good quality of data you need to have uh
amount of the quantity could be uh
anything i mean
there are several algorithm which can
work on a less amount of data but yes
you should have always a good quant
quality of a data
you we should always focus on a quality
rather than more
on a quantity so data collection is
actually a systematic approach to gather
relevant information from a variety of
sources
and this data collection which you can
actually use using data mining
algorithms
i mean some data mining techniques and
also you can do web strapping for data
collection
and also there are several open source
uh repositories out there in the market
wherein you can download the data and
you can start practicing
and developing your very first model we
can say hello world model
uh machine learning hello world machine
learning model so to to download the
data
we have several websites like github you
can go and login into github we have
kaggle it's a competition uh platform
wherein you can find
a lot of large amount of data for
different purpose
and we have a data hub once as i
mentioned once you have a proper
data once you collect data from various
sources then the next very
the neck the next important step is data
quality check and remediation
it's always important to have quality of
data as i mentioned
there is a simple terminology in a data
science field like you know
whatever you feed into machine whatever
you feed into algorithm maybe machine
learning or deep learning algorithm
you will get out from that the same if
you garbage if you got
if you feed the garbage you will get
garbage out of it if you fit good
quality of data you will get good
prediction out of it
so data analysis and data
cleaning processing is actually a very
important step in a
data science life cycle being a part of
data science life cycle
so let's say once you have a cross
secure data once you have
once you define yes your data call is
quality is too good
then uh the another important step is
data analysis
so uh at the end of the life cycle i'll
tell you what are those
out of this all those steps what is
actually the important step in the
entire data science
data data science life cycle so data
data analysis is like you know
you have to find out what kind of data
you have you can plot
your data points into different using
different pie chart bar
bar diagram or any other any other
plotting tools like matplotlib and c
bond and uh
you need to explore your data before
feeding into machine learning you
also need to find out okay do do i have
combination of genes combination of
protein sequences
do i have smile structures along with
the descriptors or a fingerprint
you need to check your data completely i
mean you need to analyze your data
completely
so once you analyze you can segregate
your data let's say you if you are if
you
you just wanted to work on a gene part
you can you can put only
gene related data or
or you can you can put descriptors or of
fingerprint to the
machine learning model so the very next
step is
once you have cross check your data once
you have a good quality of data and once
you know
my data is ready to go to machine
learning modeling process
so the the next step is data modeling
modeling means actually the formulating
every step and gather techniques
required to achieve the solution
so here it comes actually various
algorithms
exact algorithms like you know machine
learning algorithms like random for a
support vector machine
and deep learning algorithms and also
you can you can say uh
uh other subpart of deep learning like
you know rnn
cnn other things so what are the common
tools which
public you currently are using and which
is uh which is
currently available in the market as a
free of cost maybe some are
paid one is a matlab which is paid one
but we have a veka we have sas
enterprise miner we have alpha and miner
we have
statistica and spcs modeler these are
some of the freely available tool which
you can find out in a market you just
need to import a data
into the software and you just have to
select a
algorithm which through which algorithm
you have to build your model and
you are you will uh more this tools will
give you
all the predictions and
uh let's say a tool has given you the
prediction uh
so it could be you know the accuracy all
the validation parameters could be
accuracy
sensitivity specificity specificity and
all other stuff
but yes you should able to communicate
your result as well i mean
let's say if you have some kind of
classification problem so you should
develop your classification model and
while showing it to user or while
communicating your results to the
other third party you should always have
accuracy
or mcc score or all other classification
scores
if you have regression problem
definitely guys this terminology might
be
new to you classification regression but
in coming in coming slides we will we
will
look at into all those terminology in a
deep so
let's say if you have a regression
problem then you how you are
communicating your results whether it's
r square value or rmse or whatever you
have to
express or you have to communicate your
results proper results to the
stakeholders or the third part third
party person so
and most often you need to present your
findings to a non
non-technical audience such as marketing
team or a business executive
so you need to communicate the results
in a simple to understand
in a simple and understanding manner
so uh by collecting all these steps so
you know uh first is a data discovery
you mean you can save
data gathering data preparation model
planning model building operation
operationalization and communicate
result so you know guys
the first step second second step are
actually the most important thing uh
this is my personal experience if you if
you ask me i have been into this fields
more than around 10 years into
and i have several years of experience
in industry and academy
as well in the same field and i was i
was applying even i am applying
uh data science machine learning fields
in a biomedical data or in a life
science data or in pharma data
so being a data scientist i would
more focus on a data part because i
as i mentioned whatever you feeding into
machine learning you will get out of it
if you if you if you feed garbage you
will get garbage out of it if you fit
good quality of data
you will get better protection out of it
so that's why i more focus on our data
data part and data cleaning part data
pre-processing part and
data analytics analytics and exploratory
parts
then you know data scientists they they
plan
which based on the data which algorithm
should i go which algorithm should i use
whether my machine learning supplies my
need or i i should jump into deep
learning or this is the problem of
[ __ ]
natural language processing this all a
part of a model planning
then you'll do model building using
those algorithms and then
you will communicate those results uh so
guys
as of now please let me know if you have
any questions on this
uh if you have any questions you can
unmute yourself and
you can you can ask me questions
so i asks how is the drug structure
drawn so there are several
uh online open source uh software tools
available
uh maybe after this session we can put
all those links to this chat box
so considering that we don't have any
questions
as of now okay
okay so guys let us let us speak
something about
why these are so data scientists machine
learning artificial intelligence
and deep learning natural language
processing computer vision
let us differentiate all other
terminologies one by one one by one in
the coming slides
so actually ai data science and machine
learning all work in a tandem
machine learning is a field of actually
data science that fits computers
huge amount of data so so they can learn
to make insightful decisions similar to
the way that humans do for example let's
say
let us take some a random example from
your day to day life and then again
we'll move into your life science data
so most humans learn for children uh
what you
learn as a children what a flower is
without thinking about it
however the human brain achieves that
learning through experience by
collecting data on which specific
feature are associated with the flower
let's say if you're if you if you could
if you are seeing the
rose as a flower every day based on
those features
red color that shape size height
everything based on that you will
identify
this particular flower could be an uh
rose
similar way we have to feed few features
to a machine
let's say if we are building a model for
a pipe
for a flower so we have to feed those
features to
a machine saying that okay this
particular flower has a red color this
have some height this is the shape for a
flower
this is a dimension this this flowers
actually comes in
this particular time frame this uh could
be a part of big tree small tree
these all all the actually parameters or
features for those flower once we feed
into those features
machine will understand okay this
features belongs to the rows
and then finally machine will predict
okay this this
if particular features come in the
future then machine will understand okay
yes
this is this is actually a flower let me
give you one another example which is
actually booming
currently in new zealand everywhere like
autonomous self-driving cars right
so how these cars are actually working
on
so let's say uh driverless cars right so
if somebody is i mean nobody is driving
the car
in a driverless car but if some some any
object comes in front of the car let's
say
cat or a dog target stops over there if
the brake automatically
the system in a car they will they will
they will
they'll put the brakes down right why so
this is this is called a computer vision
problem so let me let me tell you this
camera in a car
they will capture the image okay let's
say if cat come in
in front of the car the camera will
capture okay this is a
car cat photo okay then machine learning
it will it will derive all the features
from from that image
and from that features already they have
trained all the
features of the cat using machine
learning or deep learning algorithm
and based on those features machine
learning or deep learning will predict
okay this these are actually features
for a cat and then
we have to stop just because cat has
come
in front of the car and we have to stop
our car right away
because it has come in front of our car
so this is how
deep learning machine learning or data
science field works
so a machine can do same thing with a
human
as human feeds the machine massive
quantities of data
it can learn that various petals steam
and other features all connected to a
floor at the same example uh if i have
to take an example
in uh in our let's say chemistry point
of view
you if you are aware with the chemo
informatics if you are aware with the
chemical data so let's say if you have a
paracetamol molecule you you have a 2d
structure or a 3d structure of a
paracetamol molecule
then the next step is what exactly you
have to do you have to calculate
the features of paracetamol the features
could be paracetamol
have an o h group paracetamol have
carboxylic group
it has a benzene ring so you have all
those features of those paracetamol
so then you have to feed in those
features into
algorithm could be a machine learning
random for a support vector machine k
means
any algorithm and then machine will
predict okay if
such features are there so these
features are actually belongs to
paracetamol if
in the future if any such kind of
features come into into this model
the model will predict okay this this
features actually belongs to paracetamol
and then it will predict yes this
this molecule is a paracetamol molecule
so this is how
this this uh machine learning data
science or deep learning it actually
works
so i'll again these are just a
superficial example i'll go and
i'll go in a very deep to explain you
what
how exactly it works how what
mathematics is behind
all those algorithms
okay
any questions so far guys
yeah so as i mentioned there are
several uh terminologies out there right
so data science artificial intelligence
machine learning deep learning natural
language processing and computer vision
these are all terminologies
you can see a part of the data science
okay now you might have heard all these
terminologies now
let's understand what exactly these are
and why we are learning about it
right so you you can say data science is
a kind of a big
bubble uh similar to that big data is
actually also a big bubble so
artificial intelligence is act is
another bubble in a data science or is
actually a part of a data science and
then machine learning
comes into a completely comes into
artificial intelligence and then neural
networks
you might have heard about multi-layer
perceptron these are
part of a neural network so this neural
network comes into a
machine learning uh domain and then we
have a deep neural network
so if we have a single layer it is
called simple neural network if we have
a multiple layers more than two
so it is called a deep neural network or
a deep learning it is also comes
comes as a part of a neural network so
hierarchy is like data science is a very
big bubble
in that we have artificial intelligence
into that we have a machine learning
into that we have neural network center
and and finally a small bubble which
comprises all this
uh deep neural networks or deep learning
so now
hope you understand how this how this
terminologies are actually linking and
why we are we have why we are calling
all this terminology several times
okay so with this
let us move on each and every uh
categories i would say or algorithms or
broader categories of algorithms one by
one
so let us talk about machine learning
so you know guys before going forward
before moving forward let me
uh again explain you uh let's say
there is a small baby there is no small
child we
uh we we teach him every time okay uh
this is a spoon this is how you have to
talk this is how you have to call this
is how
uh this is this is how you have to get
out of your bed this is how you have to
walk
so we feeding every each and every
information to the child right
so likewise this algorithms or you can
say this machine
we have to feed each and every
information to the machine
and uh another example
you might have seen the robot movie from
the rajnikanth if you are
india and uh let's say how the rope
how the brain of that robot works you
know this is everything is artificial
intelligence
it contains as you've seen as you have
seen it is a it is
maybe a combination of machine learning
deep learning neural networks all those
algorithms
so this robot brain is actually um
artificial intelligence so
while developing while creating a robot
all while developing a robot brain
they are they feed each and every
information to the robot
this is how you have to walk this is how
you have to jump this is how
you have to get in from your bed this is
how you have to uh
take a spoon all these things they
they'll teach
they'll teach to robot so this is a
machine
wherein you have to teach this machine
as a child
okay so let us let us go a small
definition of a machine learning
so machine learning algorithms enables
the computer to learn from a data
and even improves themselves without
being explicitly programmed
so as you uh so what exactly this
definition meaning is you know
initially you have to feed data to the
machine and then
based on your data machine can
understand okay this is how i have to
act this is how
i have to react but in the further
events
eventually machine keeps on learning
themselves
let's say in the let's say in further if
you feed if you keep on
feeding the data and whatever machine is
predicting based on his
experiences machine keeps on learning
whatever he has predicted whether this
prediction is correct or not
if it is correct it will understand if
it is not next time it will avoid to do
that particular wrong prediction so this
is how machine learning works and
without being explicitly programmed
means you don't have to tell each and
every time
so actually we have to make our
algorithm or our
pipeline so that our algorithm should
learn
itself in a further in a subsequent
subsequent events
of our process so machine learning is a
category of algorithm that allows
software application to become more
accurate in predicting
outcomes without being explicitly
programmed so
uh like google if you are typing
something let's say if you are searching
for a shoes in a google
very next day or maybe in next two or
three days you will get several ads from
a
shoes companies to your maybe to your
gmail maybe to
or maybe in your any of the social media
sites maybe if you are browsing through
facebook these ads will come up auto
automatically
because they'll understand okay you
google will i mean this
this algorithms at the back end they
have algorithm so they'll understand
okay you are searching for issues and
they'll
immediately they'll keep on showing
those shoes ads to your your
uh your browsing panel wherever it is
whether it is a
browser whether it is a social media
might be facebook or anywhere
so the basic premise of machine learning
is to build algorithm that can receive
input data and use statistical analysis
to predict an
output while updating output as a new
data becomes available
so again while building a model there
are several steps which i'll i'll let
you know i mean
we have to divide our data into training
say test set validation set
and we can build a model using training
set and we can use test data to
to to find out how my model performs
very well for
unknown data and again on a validation
data
so let me let me walk you each and every
step in
a coming slide
so machine as i said machine learning is
used everywhere from automating tasks to
offering intelligent insights industries
in every sector
try to benefit from it you can apply
machine learning algorithms in business
in your life science data in finance
in id sector if you have to manage your
computer processing or if you have to
find when
when your computer that is called mlaps
if you have to find when your computer
is going to get
shut down in in in how many hours you
can you can even predict using machine
learning
if you have to find out at what time
period your your computer heart is gonna
get full you can you can again you can
find this information
or you can predict this using machine
learning
and other examples are like you know
drugs classification you can classify
all your drugs let's say if you are a
chemist you can you can classify your
drugs on
let's say benzopyral category or indole
containing green category
or many other chemical class categories
you can you can predict the toxicity of
molecules and you can generate even new
molecules
using machine learning there are several
companies like
pfizer they have they have generated new
molecules without being synthesized in a
lab they have generated new molecules
using
gan generative uh generative networks
there are even several algorithms out
there you know
out there uh so where by which you can
generate a new molecule
and uh you might have heard natural
language processing
you can generate a new sentence if you
are talking something machine can
machine can generate new sentences after
you're after your sentence
so these are all everything can be
possible uh using
all this data science or machine
learning technologies and the very best
example is like you know
uh you have you you might be wearing
these fitbit bands and
you might be using google home or siri
or alexa in your day to day
activity these are all part these are
all possible just because of this
ai world or data science world or the
machine learning deep learning
algorithms so i hope
you don't have any questions so far
yes so we have one question is same
machine learning work in computer chess
game
yes uh in a competition game also they
we have ai system yes exactly
so guys if you feel shy to ask questions
publicly
uh by admitting your mic you can you can
please
type your question in a chat box plea
open has
said please explain mlp please i assure
you priya will have several
slides over after this about nlp and
other algorithms as well
so guys uh let us speak down something
into a history of artificial
intelligence or history of a data
science how
when it has started so actually uh
these algorithms were available uh to
the scientific
community late in 1950s uh but you know
uh because of a lack of
data because of uh proper data because
that time data big data technologies was
not there
so because of that we we were not having
organized data in a
in a public resource so that's why this
algorithm although they
they were this algorithm but nobody was
using this algorithm and
another point is like computational
power previously if you have seen
early 19th century computer or early
1950s 1960s computer they are actually
very big computers
now you have the entire a competitor
like uh
like they may occupy entire room now
those such
big computers have came down into your
laptop or even you can uh
maybe your small desktop or something
so that's why this algorithm was in a
hidden state
we can say even i can say but yes
eventually
uh this algorithm came into picture many
people where you
start using many people have start using
these algorithms and they start
modifying their algorithm based on the
data and
they were getting very proper output
once the data is available
to those algorithm so i i can say
1990s or 2000 could be a very
good point to start with i mean people
have started using machine learning
algorithm everywhere
and eventually after 2010 or
uh in between 2000 uh 2000 to 2018 we
could see
the evolution of a deep learning
uh many researchers from google and
facebook they
they developed several algorithms that
and they published they made it a public
they made it free to public
uh you have all those deep learning
algorithm and other computer vision and
nlp algorithms
so just a minute
yes lewis uh so yes uh the goal of this
entire course is you know we will we
will
explain you each and everything this is
being a very
uh first session so we wanted each and
everyone to be
to bring on a single platform so that's
why we are explaining
everything to correlate with your
day-to-day life but yes from the next
session
we will we will we will give each and
every example related to pharmaceutical
or life science
okay so
what are the uh so you you understood
what exactly machine learning is
so then let us learn something about
what are the types of
machine learning so yes there are
different types of machine learning
one is a supervised machine learning
second is the unsupervised machine
learning and third one is the
reinforcement learning
so the very first is a supervised
machine learning so in the supervised
machine learning we have a
classification and regression
so as i mentioned let's say guys let me
directly jump into example and then i'll
explain you what exactly it is
so let's say again talking on a
biomedical perspective let's say you
have a set of molecules
and you need to find out whether this
particular molecule could pass a
blood brain barrier or not okay so you
will have a two set of molecule one set
of
molecules would be those molecules which
could pass blood brain barrier
and another set of molecules which
doesn't pass blood blood brain barrier
okay and you have labeled all those
molecules let's say
molecule one crosses blood brain barrier
molecule two yes crosses blood pressure
barrier molecule three doesn't cross
blood pressure
molecule four yes crosses molecule five
doesn't cross
so let's say you have such such kind of
molecules uh maybe you have
a thousand molecules and out of
thousands for you could cross
blood-brain barrier and rest of the
sorry 500 could cause blood-brain
variant and rest of the 500
may not cross blood-brain barrier okay
so this is called a label data right
so you have all those molecules and you
know these molecules can
cross or cannot cross blood brain
barrier so this is called a label data
so using this label data and the and as
you have
only two classes you you can say
categories
right you have whether it is cross it
will not cross this is a kind of a true
or
false example right so you can say such
kind of examples as a classification
example
okay again let me let me give you some
real time i mean real life example or a
day-to-day example let's say if you want
a predictor how
price of a house price of a house could
be you know a
million one million dollar few thousand
dollars or could be 300 3.5 million
dollars right
so so this price of a house could be uh
could be a what i can say
variable right this this variable is the
continuous variable i mean
you have those values this is not kind
of a true or false
you are not for predicting the price of
a house
you you cannot do true whether it is
true or false but you have to predict
some values out of it
right so such if you have
if you want to predict some values then
you have to use some regression problem
hope you understood uh what this
classification and regression
again if you so classification algorithm
can be used for you know image
classification as i mentioned using a
2d molecular structure you can predict
whether this molecule is a toxic or
non-toxic so it could be a it can be an
image classification problem
so you can you can identify fraud
detection
i mean you can uh let's say you have
two types of let's say if i'm up uh if
i'm working on a banking data
and you have all the transaction many a
few of the transaction might be a
normal transaction and a few of the
transaction could be a fraud transaction
you can take those transaction details
and you can build machine learning model
and you can if the new transaction comes
in you can easily identify whether this
transaction is a fraud transaction or a
normal transaction by the customer or by
the
bank user so
uh for regression model like you know
you can uh the kind of examples are like
you know advertising popularity
prediction way you can do weather
forecasting
you can do market forecasting there are
several uh other algorithm for
forecasting as well like lstm and uh rn
and
algorithm so there are several other use
cases of classification regression
algorithm
in your research activity also in your
day-to-day life okay so unsupervised
machine learning algorithm this is also
another part of a
machine learning algorithm so as i
mentioned if you have a label data
could be a house price could be a toxic
or non-toxic could be a fraud or a
non-profit transaction
whether you have to forecast your
weather i mean
uh these are all the label data i mean
the data which you have
it is completely labeled you know this
data belongs to this particular category
so that category or that variable is
actually called as a bi variable
later on coming coming sessions i'll
explain you
how we define x variable y variable in
the
uh algorithm in the machine learning
algorithm so uh
so if you have a label data you can go
for a supervised machine learning
algorithms
and if you have unsupervised let's say
guys you have a random data
maybe let's say if somebody many any of
you have gone to
web sources website several website and
you just copy pasted
the random data into different files or
in a single file
you have copy pasted several sentences
you might have
gathered all the images from the google
images
maybe a thousand images from the google
images and you have gathered in one
place
but you don't know which image belongs
to which data or otherwise
you don't have that time to label that
data if if you
if you have brought up if let's say
out of those thousand images there may
be a hundred cat images or
500 elephant elephant images but you
don't have time to
classify those images or you don't have
time to label those images or
you you have you you have just random
data
could be any case right in that case
it means you don't have a label data so
it means
in this in such cases it is called
unsupervised
machine learning algorithm uh in in such
cases we have to use unsupervised
machine learning algorithm
and this is called unsupervised problem
or unsupervised classification problem
so how you tackle this such problems
uh in a different way right so there
could be a two problems one is a
clustering another is a dimensionality
reduction
so so you know uh the way
it should not be a part of actually
unsupervised but yes you know
here in the you will just gain some uh
meaningful insights from the data using
dimensionality reduction
uh maybe uh you can you can you can
calculate those features and you can get
only selected features for
for those data but yes the very
important algorithm
the set of algorithms are you know
clustering algorithms so
there are several okay means clustering
there are several algorithms which can
help you out to make a
as this algorithm the category clearly
defines that it's a clustering
so let's say you have a random thousand
the images
algorithm itself based on your image
features based on your image data
based on your images it will create of
several clusters
either you have to define okay i need 10
clusters or i need 15 clusters
or if you don't define machine this
algorithm itself they create a cluster
so let's say it may create a clusters of
those animals
maybe one cluster contain all those
animal images another cluster contains
maybe city images another cluster may
contain electronic gadget images
or such kind of images it will it will
cluster so this is called a clustering
algorithm okay
so what you can kind of really like
example you know customer segmentation
so let's say you have a website
and a lot of traffic traffic is coming
into your website and you have to
traffic in the sense where a lot of
visitors are visiting your website
right so uh you have to categorize those
those users into different categories
whether they belongs to
they belongs to a business people
whether they belongs to industry
employees whether it belongs to a
government employees you can categorize
those those users into different
categories using clustering algorithm
okay so i'll go through each and every
question
after this session uh maybe i can
reserve five or ten minutes for the
question and answer
so another algorithm could be a
reinforcement learning
so one of our failover he asks whether
we can use
uh this algorithm into a gaming right
yes yes reinforcement reinforcement
learning is actually
used in in various games mostly in a
chase and other other game
so this so this this algorithm is used
for you know
robot navigation real time decisions
learning task skill acquisition
so how this algorithm can use for robot
navigation right
so maybe it's better if i explain you
with all those images
in a coming slides
so let us go deep dive into
uh into those supervised unsupervised
machine learning algorithms
uh sonalika i have a question for you
shall i continue for another 10 to 15
minutes or should we stop this session
here and we can
we can open platform for a question and
answer
anyone can answer to my question
okay guys let us quickly look at this
supervised
uh all this description whatever i have
explained you let us quickly look look
at this uh
algorithm and then i look i'll be answer
i'll answer all of your questions
so classification as i mentioned you
know you can classify
various diseases disease or no disease
uh
whether it is a which color red blue may
be any kind of
this could be there should not be you
know this should not be always
only two types whether it is a true or
false or red or black or
pieces or notices there could be a
multiple categories as well you know
uh maybe protein okay this drugs belongs
to protein one protein two protein three
or protein four
here we have four different categories
right so that could that is called a
multi-class classification or a
multi-label
classification if any drug belongs to
protein 1 or either protein 2 or protein
3 or
protein 4 that is called multi-class
classification or if
one drug may belongs to protein 1 and
protein 2 or maybe protein
one and protein four or maybe protein
two and protein four that is called
multi-label classification
okay guys and we have as as we discussed
regression regression problem is when
the output variable is the real value
could be a drug activity if you have to
find out the drug activity biological
activity of a molecule
if you you have to find out the
molecular weight of a molecule if you
you have to find out uh
ic50 or k k 10 all other parameters the
algorithm which you you will use for
supervised and unsupervised algorithm
are you know linear regression logistic
regression k
nearest neighbors decision tree random
forest gradient boosting machines xgboos
support vector machines and also neural
networks
so for unsupervised learning as i
mentioned let's say you have a
random set of data at right side you
could see
a computer will automatically clusters
those data into different different
and output is dependent upon the
algorithm which algorithm you
you are gonna use it so in the
unsupervised
learning uh clustering and association
as i as i discussed the algorithm which
you are gonna use is you know k means
clustering hierarchy
clustering and neural networks can also
be used for unsupervised machine
learning
and in a uh maybe in the next section we
will look it into reinforcement learning
this is very interesting algorithm
wherein you know you will get
how exactly robot uh gets navigation
uh through through those algorithm how
we feed in data into those uh those
algorithms
and uh these are some tools or we you
can say some open source uh
platforms available for all the data
scientists to work
on such kind of problem so i would like
to
walk you through some demo but
definitely next session will i
i'm going to walk you through some code
demo how we can write those machine
learning algo i mean
this code how we can use this machine
learning for our problem we don't have
to explicitly write
a code or we don't have to do all such
mathematics being a biological student
being a
chemistry background student i don't
have to write all this algorithm there
are several packages available out there
we just have to call the package we just
have small understanding of
python and we just have to call those
packages and we are good to go
we can use we just have to feed in data
and we have to call those packages and
machine will does everything and it will
give us the prediction
in the coming slides we have several
other i'll explain you how deep learning
works what are the formulas for
deep learning what what exactly
mathematics behind deep learning
no i'll not go much deeper into the
mathematics but yes i'll definitely
correlate how you can
let's see if you are feeding your
molecular structures into
a network let's say in this network so
how how this calculation exactly
happening and how this particular thing
it is producing whether it is a
particular molecule i have
here i have taken an example of dog and
cat but yes
it will i'll explain you how you have
let's see if you have feeding
gene expression data if you have feeding
molecular descriptor or a fingerprint
what exactly happening in this hidden
layer input layer and output layer
i'll explain you a little bit of method
with a little bit of mathematics
and ah and we have lot more stuff to
cover in a coming lecture
ah in the entire session of one month so
it could be a very interesting uh
journey
with you guys me and with my other
fellow colleagues
uh from our collaborators and uh we will
be so this could be a very great
starting point for you
to jump into if you are not completely
new about data science it could be a
great starting point for you to jump
into data science field
and if you want to change your field
maybe you are working we have several
people from my industry if you really
want to change your career
this could be a i don't say this is a
blockbuster course but yes
this could be a starting point for you
based on this course you will learn many
things how
what exactly you can do in your data
science we have seen several students or
several people
being a pharmaceutical graduate being a
biological being a life science graduate
they have implemented
this algorithm they have used this
technologies in
in their own data in their pharma data
in their drug discovery data in their
life science gene expression data and
they developed several good
models or good software's out of it and
they got very well recognition
in the in their industry or in their
research
so guys i am hoping all of you for
for a next one month journey association
with all of you
and definitely you and our team will
enjoy
this entire one-month session on a data
science and you will learn many things
about data science
in the coming days so now i am open for
a question uh
hello sir sorry sir we were not there
when you called us we were in a meeting
and uh so we have a question on youtube
i just wanted to ask that
so uh el chiari asks i'm not a data
scientist but i'm looking forward to use
machine learning especially genomic and
transatomic data analysis
in my research but he doesn't know how
he can start
and he's asking which things could help
him to initiate himself in the field and
make progress
as quick as possible and that is i think
the common question of a lot many people
as well
so could you please tell uh how people
who want to make a career in data
science
how they can start yes yes thanks thanks
so much
so guys as i already mentioned
being a life science graduate even if
you don't have any experience
in a python any experience in data
science any experience in machine
learning that is that is also fine
this data science course the entire one
course is actually designed for
for you guys if you don't have any
understanding of
of a computer science or of a prop
python programming or anything
in this course we will help you out to
learn python the basics of a python we
will help you out
for a various machine learning how we
can how we can use those machine
learning or deep learning algorithms
specifically in your
uh in your life science data maybe a
genomics data may be your
transcriptomics data
so this course is actually for you guys
and we will help you out we will
we will walk you through the entire
process of data science in a
life science so i would say this is one
of
the finest course in the world
which actually applying data science in
the life science
so we have uh sonalika we have another
question what is tensorflow for
so tensorflow is used for you know deep
learning
uh models i mean it's a framework
wherein you can you can write
deep learning code and you can you can
um
uh you know you can call various deep
learning models as well using pytorch
uh and uh eras from the tensorflow
anymore we have another question can i
graduate from this course with a
knowledge to work for data visualization
uh yes you will you will get lot of
insights lot of knowledge about data
visualization into this course
we will help you out let's see if you
have if you have given an input of
a gene expression data or a
transcriptomic data we will
we will help you how you can do data
visualization how we can generate data
data graphs how you can how you can
analyze those
biological data we will help you out
entire throughout this course
so while you share more questions uh let
me just take you throughout the
important resources
so first of all those who have not
registered yet and
they are looking forward to register
themselves uh you stand the last chance
today because
we have already started with the session
and this session was a free session for
everyone
uh that's why we didn't close the
registrations yet but we would be
closing them really very soon
so to register yourself you have to go
to the omixojic portal
and if you're signed up great if you're
not then please sign up and go to the
program page
now once you go to the program page you
will have a list of all the programs
which are ongoing and the upcoming ones
here you will get machine learning for
biomedical drug discovery and also
information biomedical drug discovery is
there as well
now i'm mentioning about this because uh
it's uh
the next part of this program which we
started the biomedical drug
data science and drug discovery program
and once you go to the machine learning
for biomedical drug discovery program
page
this program page would open up to
proceed
your application you have to request for
more information
and then register yourself for the
program
here fill out all the details we'll get
your registration and we'll reach
uh back to you you can also get all
these session details here
now everyone who has enrolled uh till
today
they all have been added to this program
page now when i say they have been added
to this program page it means
that throughout this course you need to
keep this program page with you you
you can simply bookmark it and uh
whenever we have a session you will see
the
zoom link for the session just uh below
this
and also the moment we are done with the
session i would be uploading the session
video and you and you can just see the
recorded session on the program page
itself
and uh those who want to register
themselves directly by
paying so they have to just uh come to
the
options of payment we have so we have
three levels beginner intermediate and
and
advanced now these are the segregation
typically based on the provisions which
you would be having and the
provisions they are mentioned uh shin
and uh move ahead with your
payment sorry internet connection is
unstable and that's where
uh there is an issue so
this way you would have to proceed with
the payment
and those who have the promo code uh
they can just apply it here and shin
like what all topics would be covered in
each session this is the blog which we
have
i'll be sharing this blog link with you
as well here it is in the chat box now
so you can simply go to this blog and
learn
what all programs are like what all
sessions we have
and what all topics would be covered in
each of the session
and what are the various other resources
for the session everything is mentioned
in the blog itself
and for today's recording i will be
sending out the recording to everyone
and it's also there
because we went live on youtube so we
have a question
the lip is asking python alone is good
enough for the drug discovery process or
r is mandatory uh
actually python is enough but r is
mostly used for a data visualization but
we have several packages as well in
python
for a data visualization so even if
somebody knows python basic knowledge
somebody have basic knowledge of python
that is actually enough for them
i hope that answers your question the
lib
so those who have enrolled i have added
them
already to the slacks page now this is
how slack looks like
many of you might be here who are new to
slack
so uh on your mail id you would have the
invitation for the slack
and you just need to accept the
invitation and join the group
and zahara you are asking
that how can you join the slack platform
you need to be uh you need to enroll
yourself you need to be one of our
participants and then we
send you out the link because uh the
groups which we have made on slack
they're just for the participants so
that we can communicate with them all
the session details and recordings and
everything
we i would be sending out uh the session
meeting details and also the recordings
on slack after each session
so uh i think you have to be here it is
important
for you and also as elia told you that
we will be monitoring your
uh progress on the omixlogic portal and
also on the server
so we'll keep you updating here in the
group as well
who's performing best and let's see who
does
great and then we have the general group
as well where we keep on updating
everything
about our upcoming programs now talking
about the
program which we have tomorrow that is
the chem informatics for biomedical drug
discovery
program we have the first session of
the program tomorrow and those people
who are enrolled in both the programs we
have kept the session
on alternate day so that they can be a
part of both the programs
so those are interested for chem
informatics for biomedical drug
discovery
they can register themselves on the
program page
i'm sending you the link of the same and
i had today send out a promo code you
can simply put it out here
by proceeding with your application and
also we would be closing the
registrations for chem informatics
program
as well because we would be starting
tomorrow
and if you have any any doubts you can
uh mail me at
marketing at the rate find out bio and
also you
you can mail us
uh if i'm not wrong you are a
participant for all the programs for all
the four
phases and i've already added you so you
need to check your mail id
for the uh link of this for the slack
channel
and it would be definitely there and you
can
then be a part of the group if you have
any doubts you can ask suggester is here
as
well and if not then let's meet the
after tomorrow
hi sunalika um i just had a question um
just because i'm in the east coast i was
wondering
the what the schedule so it's going to
be the class is going to be
at this time every like on the scheduled
dates right
yes it would be as shared dude
uh so what time is it there for you
for me yeah it works i just um you know
i just need to mark it off on my
calendar um
um it's eight it started for me at 8 30
a.m
est and that that worked for me we still
have a lot of things to do
so um would how long is the session for
again was it i i didn't get the schedule
so
that's why i'm asking okay so the
session would be uh
a one hour um like but it could go to
one of a few minutes as well because we
keep on having discussions people would
be asking questions
and uh i would be sending out google
calendar invites also to all our
participants
uh just after the session so you would
be having each and every session updated
on your calendar
and it would be easy for you to keep a
check on all the upcoming sessions
uh i think that would work for you
right and um my next question was like
so once we have the live sessions we all
will be
able to uh we are expected to go over
the asynchronous uh sessions as well
right the pre-recorded lessons
um will we be uh able to access that
list like
okay so if you have like for the next
class the this is the pre-recorded
material that we need to watch
yes yes so here you have the
asynchronous material as well which you
can go through at your own pace
so uh the participants
they get the access to each and
everything we get the access to
all the courses and all the projects we
have sample projects as well
on our portal and i've given you the
access already
so you can go to the portal and take up
whatever course you want to so
as we are beginning with data science so
let's say you want to learn more before
of the session let's say or want to
explode more
then you're most welcome you can just
start with the date with the
courses in the data science domain start
with our python or
learn whatever you want it's completely
up to you at your own pace
thank you welcome and also
let's say uh brian starts with uh
our coding introduction to data science
and
uh once she completes the course
there are there are a number of
assignments in the course as well you
need to submit the assignments and
once you complete the course only then
you will get the certificate
and uh let me also tell you this that we
look forward
uh to updated profiles like i told you
that
we keep on communicating the progress of
each of the participants
across our different social platforms so
i want you all to please update your
profile with the profile
picture and also link all your social
accounts link your facebook linkedin
so that when we post about you across
people know who you are and what your
progress is
and it's a great way to um like stay
updated
with everything right because if you're
putting in so much
efforts then why not um
keep it on your profile as an
achievement
and you would get the certificates once
you complete the course
okay then it was nice meeting you all uh
if you still have any doubts you can ask
or else you can mail
and also dr sujeeth uh you can
meet dr sujeeta as well
we have something okay okay sarah thank
you so much for
being a part of yes sir over to you
uh hi i have a question yes yes please
answer
um i'm trying to access the t server
uh my name is mohit i'm trying to access
the
d server bio account but i'm not able to
access
invalid email or password i've had the
account for
yeah oh okay so are you using your
uh uh tba info server details which we
gave you
yeah you sent a password to my mail
right
okay so uh see uh we have actually made
few changes
to our portal we shifted uh from uh
edu portal over here that's where there
were few things that he was
updating so now now on the day by
info server you can also log in with the
login credentials you used for the
omixlogic portal
so that would work for you as well so
the id and the
password you use to log in on the omix
logic page
you can use that on the t by info server
as well
you need not require any uh extra
credentials from
us and that should work for you but
still if if it does not then you can
text me over slack or mail me and i'll
just fix it for you
does it work yeah all right thanks uh i
am logging using my gmail account so i'm
not sure what to do now
i don't have any credentials for romix
logic uh you don't have any credentials
in you need not have any
credentials so when you sign up to omex
logic
you can do so with any of your id or
password you can also do so with
your linking your social so let's say
i just sign up and
you have to make your own id and
password or you can
directly link in let's say i link in my
google account with it
and uh my net connection is little bad
that's right it would be slow sorry
but yes so the moment you sign up my id
is pop up and you choose your
account it's completely up to you that's
what i want to say creating your id and
password
so you you can do one thing do you have
any other id
except this one i can do that but i lose
the progress
uh yeah that would be an issue that
would be an issue
if you don't mind can you share your
your credentials with me
uh just after this session i'll uh try
to
make it work for you sure thanks
okay please mail me at marketing and
today find out by
your credentials and i'll just look
forward to it and i'll just fix it
okay then everyone let's meet on uh
wednesday 16th of june we have second
session
i would be looking forward to meeting
meeting you all and
uh till then bye bye take care thank you
so much dr sujeet
for the wonderful session you gave us
today
thank you
you